Here's an example of a connection table.
As we can see each record contains the
most basic information about connection.
In particular the source IP address,
source port, destination IP address,
destination port, and most importantly
the current connection state.
For example whether it's established or
not.
Internally to the firewall,
there could be another data structure
that is linked to the connection table.
For example, for web traffic,
since a page can spend multiple packets,
this internal data structure
of the firewall can maintain
the contents of a page that
it has received so far.
That is, this data structure which
is linked to the connection table
will allow the firewall to perform more
specific analysis of the connection.